Joshua is with us in Elizabethtown
Kentucky hi Joshua how are you we will
get about yourself better than I deserve
what's up in your world so I have an
opportunity for a career change I'm
currently working as a we're out
salesmen for coca-cola and I make
anywhere between you know it's a
commissioned job so I make anywhere
between 50 to 70 thousand but have the
opportunity to work as a courier for
FedEx and the plus for that is it will
pay for my schooling it will be a pay
cut but I'm thinking like in the future
you may pay off you know because they'd
be able to go to school they'll pay for
it so I was just wondering like what
what your thoughts rotor all that okay
well the coke routes as you know the
coca-cola routes are really hard work
but if you hustle and grind you can make
good money and you are you've obviously
built your route up pretty well that's
pretty good numbers and so that's not a
bad gig at all but man it's work as you
know and FedEx deliveries not not like a
walk in the park or anything that's
that's pretty heavy work too but they're
going to pick up school what do you want
to study where do you want to be in 10
years
I wanted to know for a business business
management and my goal is going to just
a pastor a church but I feel like you
know just knowing the business side of
things could help a into that mm-hmm
okay well the thing I always ask is just
because the FedEx thing popped up it's
not a bad gig but just because it popped
up is that the shortest track to your
10-year goal and so if you'll reach out
into your future and put a peg in the
ground and go that's where we're going
and then ask yourself what the
straightest line is towards that peg
that answers a lot of your question and
you've kind of done that and that you
said hey coca-cola is not a bad thing
but this other thing takes me through
education path which helps me get to
that goal in the future right and so
you're kind of doing that now I'm just
wondering if there's a fourth or fifth
or a sixth way to do your goal that is
as good or better
if not then the FedEx thing sounds like
it's at least taking you toward the your
desired future right right and so lay
out there where you want to be in the
future and you should want to be a
pastor so you know where there is no
vision the people perish so we reach out
into the future only we lay down our
vision and we say all right what are my
nine steps to get there one of my six
steps to get there how many years is it
going to take what's the process to be
doing what I want to be doing at X date
and here's what's weird as soon as you
put that in place your life starts to
form around that line and start sucking
you in that way it has a gravitational
pull and so you're already on it a
little bit here I the only thing I want
to challenge is just ask a bigger
question and say is there a shorter path
even than the fedex idea if there's not
then that's not a bad one it's not a bad
one thanks for the call - appreciate it
you know we all get stuck in orbit on
stuff don't we and his discussions he's
obviously doing a really good job of
managing his life and he's thinking out
into the future but you know Earl
Nightingale used to say that people too
often spend more time picking out a suit
of clothes and they do their next career
they just fall into it how'd you get
that job my friend was working there
that's a dumb reason to take a job I
mean is that the best you got really you
know well my family always worked there
well have you looked at them I mean
really is that where you want to be if
it is it's okay but I mean you need to
have a real reason is it taking you
where you want to go because I got to
tell you when you do nothing stupid has
a gravitational pull
you'll get locked into orbit around
stupid and it will eventually pull you
into itself and you'll go down the
vortex man and you just live your life
as below average or mediocre if you're
not careful and so reach out there and
look in the future and go intentionally
even if it's hard even if it feels
impossible where do I want to be in 10
years where do I want to be in 20 years
when I'm 72 and got grandbabies bouncing
on my knee what do I want my life to
look like and what are the steps to get
it there and that's on your career size
I obviously works with all the financial
stuff we talk
about that'll lead you out of debt onto
a budget into saving and investing so
you can live that desired future with
your dream living the dream is Hogan
says dream in HD Chris Hogan talks about
that all the time with retire inspired
materials hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]